le web avant l'an 2000 ça ressemblait à
ça la préhistoire d'internet dans le
monde seuls 40 millions de personnes
sont connectées au web en 1994 en france
c'est cette même année qu'internet
devient accessible au grand public
alors le minitel voyait se casser quoi
internet exactement le minitel séparées
sauf que c'est mondiale alors c'est le
réseau de tous les raisons vous brancher
sur internet vous pouvez communiquer
avec tous les ordinateurs du monde
consultez la météo aux états unis
prévoir un voyage en métro à paris
visiter certains musées le monde entier
est désormais à portée de clic
à cette période il faut alors passer par
les universités
quelques écoles ou bien dès 1995 par ce
lieu le premier cyber café de paris
je sais pas si on n'arrive pas à trouver
internet n'est pas encore entré dans
notre quotidien mais déjà en 1995 des
chercheurs alerté sur les risques du
réseau n'importe qui peut émettre de
l'information n'importe qui peut éditer
un journal
bien sûr ça veut dire que si les gens
sont libres
il faut aussi qu'ils sont responsables
la circulation des infos en tout genre
même les plus sensibles
en 1996 la première affaire de
pédopornographie sur le net
éclate en france autre problème plus
délicat à traiter qui apparaît dans le
web d'avant 2000 les arnaques à la carte
bleue via des faux sites de vente comme
cet amateur de musique qui s'est fait
pirater ces données en 1999
bonjour et la totale y avait mon nom mon
adresse mon email noms numéros de cartes
de crédit et sa date d'expiration
à cette époque internet en france et
surtout un sujet de curiosité à peine
0,9 pour cent de la population est
connectée au réseau chiffre qui grimpe à
13,9 pour cent en 2000 bien loin des 84
% recensés fin 2018
[Musique]